كان ملف الغاز مع اسرائيل من اكثر الملفات
اثاره للجدل في مصر وهو ما حوكم بسببه
قربون من الرئيس المخلوع محمد حسني مبارك
ولكن توقف هذا الامر بعد ثوره ال5 من
يناير واثناء حكم المجلس العسكري ثم فتره
حكم الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي الا ان
العلاقات المصريه الاسرائيليه عادت لت
تحسن بقوه بعد انقلاب الثالث من يوليو عام
2013 واصبحت مصر تستورد الغاز الاسرائيلي
لماذا وهل مصر في حاجه الى الغاز
الاسرائيلي تحديدا نناقش الموضوع بعد
تقرير مريم
ابيش غزو اسرائيل في مصر كم من فتيل ازمه
سيشعل في بلد غارق في المشاكل لم تهدا
زوبعه استيراد الاردن الغاز من دوله
الاحتلال حتى فجر خبر الصفقه المصريه
بقيمه 20 مليار دولار لتزويدها بالغاز
الاسرائيلي قنبله من العيار الثقيل حتى
وان لم تكن الاولى منذ قررت جمهوريه مصر
العربيه التطبيع مع الدوله العبريه ورد في
تفاصيل الخبر الذي تناقلته وسائل الاعلام
المصريه ان مده الصفقه المثيره للجدل هي
20 عاما ابرمت بعد زياره وفد اسرائيلي من
مجموعه تمار للقاهره استغرقت بضع ساعات
ابرز ما اتفق عليه الطرفان هو مد خط
انابيب جديد للغاز يمتد من حقول تمار الى
مصر بتكلفه نحو نصف مليار دولار كما تقرر
تفعيل مذكره التفاهم الموقعه سابقا لشراء
خمس حجم المخزون الاستراتيجي للغاز في حقل
تمار اي حوالي 60 مليار متر مكعب توقفت
مفاوضات بيع الغاز الاسرائيلي لمصر بعد
اندلاع ثوره يناير وخلال فتره حكم المجلس
العسكري ثم الرئيس محمد مرسي لكنها
استؤنفت بعد الانقلاب العسكري ووصول
المشير عبد الفتاح السيسي الى السلطه
ودخلت العقود حيز التنفيذ بدء من
2014 علاقه القاهره بالغاز الاسرائيلي
ليست جديده الجديد وتبادل الادوار فمن
مصدر تحولت مصر الى مستورد في 2012 انهار
اتفاق التصدير الذي مدته 15 عاما بعد
الهجمات المتكرره على خط في شبه جزيره
سيناء الصفقه التي تاتي في سياق سياسه
تطبيع لا تلقى ترحيبا شعبيا اعادت جدلا
خفتا لكنه لم يغب كيف تشتري دول عربيه من
اسرائيل غازا تسرقه من الفلسطينيين وال
اللبنانيين والسوريين بل وحتى المصريين
برضاها او رغما عنها تنازلت الدول صاحبه
الحق في عده حقول استغلتها اسرائيل
والاخطر الا تجد بعض الانظمه حرجا في
ابرام صفقات يراها بعض المعارضين مشبوهه
مع دوله محتله على سبيل المثال حقل
ليفيتون يقع في شرق البحر الابيض المتوسط
وتحديدا داخل المياه الاقليميه لفلسطين
المحتله وبالقرب من سواحل غ
اكتشف عام 2010 ويقدر مخزونه باكثر من 600
مليار متر مكعب من غاز معظمه مخصص للتصدير
لماذا لجات مصر الى عدو الامس وهي التي
اكتشفت عام
2015 حقل ظهر حقل يعتقد انه يحتوي على
اكبر احتياطي للغاز الطبيعي في المتوسط
ومن قبلها الم تجد المملكه الاردنيه غير
تل ابيب لتسترد منها لان صوت الشارع الع
ربي مهما قال وانتفض لم يعد مسموعا تمضي
الانظمه في سياسه حتما ليست وفيه للدماء
التي سالت في الحروب العربيه ضد الكيان
الصهيوني وينضم الينا من فرايبورج في
المانيا عضو مجلس الشعب المصري السابق
الدكتور حاتم عزام ومن واشنطن الدكتور
نبيل ميخائيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن دكتور نبيل ابدا منك
لماذا لجات مصر لاستيراد الغاز من اسرائيل
تحديدا وفي صفقه طويله المدى على مدى 15
عاما وبقيمه 20 مليار
دولار ا ارحب بحضرتك والدكتور حاتم
المشاهدين والمشاهدات اه الاجابه لان هناك
حاجه مصريه اقتصاديه بحته تتطلب من
القاهره ان توقع هذا العقد بتلك الشروط
سواء السعر سواء الفتره الزمنيه او سواء
المصدر ا يعني الباحث في هذا المضمار لن
يعرف تفاصيل كثيره لكن هو واقع مهم وما
بدا في خطه طويله الامد يعني ان هتكون لها
تاثير ايضا على الاقتصاد المصري والاقتصاد
الفلسطيني والاقتصاد العربي واقتصاديات
البحر المتوسط لان اسرائيل نفسها في
تطورها لامكانيات الطاقه الخاصه بها تحاول
اقامه شبكه من العلاقات مع قبرس والى حد
ما مع اليونان
فهي يعني منظومه اقتصاديه جديده فمن
الناحيه الاقتصاديه هذا امر مبرر وهذا امر
سيوافق عليه لكن الجانب السياسي هو الشق
الاصعب هناك عده اسئله مطروحه ما طبيعه
المناقشه التي ستدور في المحتوى السياسي
المصري سواء في مجلس النواب او على شاشات
الفضائيات او في مواقع اخرى بخصوص تلك
الصفقه الامر الاخر هل هذا قرار سيادي ك
كما هو يعرف الان بمعنى لو نوقش الامر هل
سيكون الرد هذا قرار سيادي يمس المصلحه
القوميه العليا فلا داعي لمناقشته في غالب
الاحوال سيطرح هذا الراي على انه المبرر
لتوقيع تلك الصفقه طيب حسنا يعني على
الاقل الاخر والاخير هو اتفضل افضل
دكتور شكرا ا الامر الاخر هو ما تاثير هذا
على العلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه التي تعرف يعني باسلوب
دبلوماسي بانها مازالت سلام بارد على على
الرغم من اقتراب موعد يعني 40 سنه على
توقيع اتفاقيه معاهده السلام ما بين مصر
واسرائيل تقريبا من يعني من 38 سنه فهل
سيكون السلام المصري الاسرائيلي مازال
سلام بارد كولد بيس حتى بعد مرور تلك
السنوات وحتى مع توقيع هذه الصفقه الهامه
حسنا حاج غل الباحثين السياسيين الدكتور
حاتم عزام هل المبرر هو حاجه
اقتصاديه محضه ام ترى امرا
اخر تحياتي لحضرتك يا استاذ عثمان ولضيفك
الكريم والساده المشاهدين الحقيقه لم اسمع
مداخله الضيف كامله ولكن يعني خلاصه خلاصه
القول انه يقول ان الحاجه هي حاجه
اقتصاديه محضه دفعت الى هذا القرار خليني
اقول لحضرتك حاجتين اول شيء ما ما يحدث في
هذه الصفقه
ليس ببعيد عن الاطار السياسي العام الذي
تمارسه سلطه انقلاب الثالث من يوليو
العسكري اللي بتخضع كل ادوات القوه في
الدوله المصريه
الى سلطه الاح اذا سمحت لي دكتور قد نعود
الى الجانب السياسي ولكن هل هل بالفعل
هناك حاجه اقتصاديه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
لا توجد اي حاجه الى هذا لسببين اثنين اول
شيء هناك بدائل عربيه 100% امنه كالدوره
القطريه و والجمهوريه الجزائريه وحتى لو
تخيلنا انه سلطه الانقلاب العسكري يعني
تعتبر الدوله القطريه الان عدو اكثر من
السلطه الاسرائيل سلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فان هناك الجمهوريه الجزائريه
ودوله قطر والجزائر من من كبار مصدي الغاز
في المنطقه والمواصفات الغاز المستخرج
هناك والامكانات اللوجستيه والفنيه تسمح
اقتصاديا بتصديرها سواء من قطر او من
الجزائر الى مصر دي نمره واحد نمره اثنين
هناك اعلان عن كشف كبير جدا فه في ظهر
بتاع شركه اني وتم اعلان انه ستكتفي مصر
من الغاز وتم ترويج الكثير من الاوهام حول
هذا فنحن نتساءل كيف تعلنون ان هناك يعني
هذا الكشف سيغطي انتاج مصر من الغاز ثم
تستورد الغاز من اسرائيل
وبالتالي انا لن اخوض في حتى في الماضي
وان هذا استكم مال لمسلسل بداه حسني مبارك
وسامح فهمي لانه حتى رئيس الوزراء الان
اللي هو شريف اسماعيل بتاع السيسي هو كان
وكيل وزاره البترول لشؤون الغاز ايام سامح
فهمي وصدق على اتفاقيه تصدير الغاز
لاسرائيل فانت بعت الغاز لاسرائيل باقل من
دولار بحوالي 75 سنت المليون وحده حراريه
والان تستورده بمليارات الدولارات طيب
دعني اطرح ساع اليك دعني اطرح هذا السؤال
على الدكتور نبيل ميخائيل الدكتور نبيل
قيل انه تم اكتش شاف اكبر حقل في في في
المتوسط في مصر هذا الكلام في 2015 و15
وفي 15 من فبراير رئيس الشركه المصريه
القابضه للغازات الطبيعيه قال ان مصر
ستوقف الاستيراد من
2018 لماذا اذا الان تعقد الصفقه بهذا اي
الحجم اذا كنت ستوقف الاستيراد وا اكتشفت
اكبر حقل وتحديدا مع اسرائيل رغم وجود
بدائل كما يقول الدكتور حاتم عزا
هنا الباحث هيط تكهنات
ربما تكون تصريحات المسؤول المصري غير
دقيقه وغير سليمه ده احتمال الامر الاخر
هو ان الصفقه على الرغم من يعني مضمونها
الاقتصادي هي صفقه سياسيه ايض على فكره
نحن نتحدث يعني انت تقول قد تكون غير
سليمه اريد اشير للتاريخ فقط انه هذا
التصريح كان في الخامس 10 من فبراير
الماضي يعني وقت قريب جدا ومن شخص بهذا
المستوى هي مشكله ليه هي برض يعني سؤال
صعب ل انا لا اعرف دوافعه في ان هو يطرح
ارقام
تخالف الطاقات الاقتصاديه لمصر يعني حتى
اللي سمعناه مؤخرا ان السعوديه بدات في
شحن بترولها مره اخرى لمصر والعراق وافق
على انه يزود مصر باحتياجاته من البترول
فهنا في اكثر من سبلاير في اكثر من عارض ل
حااجه الطلب ف يعني التصريحات يجب ان تكون
اكثر دقه اكثر شفافيه لكن لو الجانب
الاقتصادي يعني ليس على صواب العامل
السياسي هيكون في المقام الاول زي مثلا
لما تكون دولتين على خلاف لكن علاقه
اقتصاديه ما قد تساهم في تخفيف حده الوطا
يعني حتى في دراسات العولمه هناك مثل يقال
لا توجد دولتان يحاربان بعضهما اذا كان كل
واحده منهم عندها محل ماكدونالدز فهناك
رابطه اقتصاديه ما تحاول تخفيف الوطاه
السياسيه وال الفجوه ما بين دولتين مصالح
مصالح اذا دكتور حاتم عزام الا يمكن يعني
سياسيا براغماتيا ان يبرر هذا اعتبرها
رشوه سياسيه لاسرائيل لارضاء قوى عظمى مثل
الولايات المتحده لارضاء حتى اي اسرائيل
من اجل مصالح تتعلق بالامن
القومي المصري هل يمكن ان يكون هذا
التبرير السياسي
واردا هو التبرير السياسي الوارد من وجهه
نظري انه هذه السلطه التي اتت عبر انقلاب
عسكري هي بالتحديد مدعومه من اسرائيل منذ
اليوم الاول وتم اعلان السيسي في صفحات
المجلات الاسرائيليه والصحافه الاسرائيليه
انه بطل القوم لاسرائيل
وقيل انه ها انه ان هناك سلام دافئ واحضام
دافئه للسلام الان بين نتنياهو وبين
السيسي والسيسي صرح ان نتنياهو رجل عظيم
وقائد عظيم فليس هناك كما يقول الدكتور من
الولايات المتحده انا اتفهم طبعا هو قد
يكون يعني يحاول الا يمس اسرائيل بسوء وهو
في الولايات المتحده ولكن انا بقول لحضرتك
تصريحات السيسي واضحه جدا انه مرتم في حضن
هذه السلطه المحتله واسرائيل هي داعم
اساسي
بل السبب الرئيسي في هذا الانقلاب
العسكري دوليا النقطه الاخرى ما يحدث في
سيناء ليس ببعيد عن هذه الصفقات هذه
الصفقات التي تتم الان هي اخضاع للقرار
السيادي المصري ورهنه مستقبليا لمصلحه
اسرائيل عن طريق خلق
اعتماديه على مصادر الطاقه ونحن نعلم ان
مصادر الطاقه تشن من اجلها الحروب وما
يعني احتلال العراق عنا ببعيد وما تدخل
القوى العظمى وروسيا في سوريا الان ببعيد
عن الغاز والنفط وبالتالي خلق ه هذه
الاعتماديه على مصادر النفط الاسرائيليه
بتاع سلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالمناسبه
خليني اقول لك ان شركه تماره تنتج من حقل
التمار ده الان هذا الحقل عليه
ديسبيوتالين
مقدمه طلب في الامم المتحده بتقول انه هذا
هذه في المياه الاقليميه التجاريه اللبنان
فنحن امام سلطه احتلال تسرق الغاز من
الدول العربيه وامام للاسف عاصمه عربيه
وهذا اخذ عليه تعليقه من الدكتور نبيل
ميخائيل في اقل من دقيقه من فضلك غاز يسرق
من اللبنانيين من الفلسطينيين حتى من
المصريين فكيف
يبرر ان ان ان تستورده مصر التي كانت
مصدرا للغاز الى اسرائيل منذ سنوات
قليله اثناء الحرب البارده وبعدها
كان هناك توتر شابه علاقات موسكو بواشنطن
لكن على الرغم من هذا كان مثلا في تصدير
للغاز الروسي من سيبيريا الى دول حليفه
الامريكا في اوروبا الغربيه او الولايات
المتحده نفسها فالعلاقات الاقتصاديه
تتجاوز الخلافات السياسيه اما عن سرقه
اسرائيل لغاز لبناني او فلسطيني على تلك
الدول ان تقدم شكوى الى الهيئات الدوليه
المختصه بتلك الامور لان اولا ده هيط
الامور على حقيقتها وكمان حيكون وسيله
لاستعاده لحقوقهم لكن لن يكون عائق في ان
توقع مصر اتفاق مع اسرائيل ممكن مصر تعرف
ان هذا الغاز غاز اسرائيلي قادم من لبنان
لكن العلاقات مستمره ولا يشكل عائقا كما
تقول شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن الدكتور
نبيل ميخائيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن ومن فرايبورج في
المانيا عضو مجلس الشعب المصري السابق
الدكتور حاتم عزان